oh sorry sorry stay at the race track
you know how it is look I got on
someone's desk economy shoulders as well
it looks like my name hmm looks like
your name look who knows who this real
temperatures is all I know is that it's
Friday and it's not for games what news
top-five it's sure and it's time to
hydrate so you probably know
free-to-play MEC shoot a whole camp
Holton came out on the state was just
rotating because you don't know I don't
know it anyway came out on Steam in 2014
and now it's going off steam again
really arrived on consoles in June of
last year so it hit Xbox one and ps4 but
the dev have announced that they are
pulling it from steam reloaded games
announced that they're going to refocus
development efforts and that's pretty
much the only reason they've given for
why they're pulling it from PC but
presumably it's because they found more
of an audience on consoles and PC I can
only use here I guess that makes sense
you don't want to focus on the platform
it's you know giving you the most
bidness yeah I mean like I said they
haven't explicitly come out with
anything other than that but they have
said that the game is being removed from
sale so it won't be available on Steam
anymore as of January 2nd it will still
be on Xbox one and ps4 but also for PC
players all DLC is unavailable as of
this week you won't be able to get in
tonight either so good a while since
we've spoken about pub G it has been a
while pub G developer blue hole this
week it seems like they're talking to
Microsoft to extend the exclusivity deal
on Xbox one for consoles for console
versions of pub G according to Bloomberg
they have some sources who have asked to
remain anonymous saying that Microsoft
is in talks with all the major players
about console versions of player owns
battlegrounds and that their talks in
particular and Microsoft are about
extending bigger meat exclusivity and
it's Sony it's about what they're gonna
do with the ps4 version wants that
exclusivity and yeah of course we don't
know what the exclusive lengths
deal anything is with the Xbox version
yeah no one's actually come out and said
this is exactly what
deal is and it sounds like we're
probably not going to know until launch
at this stage what it is supposed to
launch this year on Xbox one and it is a
console launch exclusive so a bit of an
update for you on the Ubisoft Vivendi
saga give us a quick refresher longest
time so basically uh Vivendi have
something of a history of buying large
stakes in game companies publicly traded
game companies publicly traded companies
that they then overtake without the
company really wanting to be overtaken
that's the term hostile takeovers so the
same thing happened with Activision
Blizzard and used to earn a stake in
them and they bought themselves back and
right now it's happening with Ubisoft
even though Vivendi have publicly gone
on record to say that they are not
trying to buy out Ubisoft
their actions would speak otherwise they
currently hold a twenty seven percent
stake in Ubisoft but yourself has been
really outspoken they do not want to be
bought out by Vivendi they think it's
going to affect their ability to
innovate and be agile and what they've
done is figured out how to buy back four
million of their own shares so if you be
stopped manage to go ahead and ascertain
these four million shares it would mean
that no one could buy them out Vivendi
included so they're hoping to get all of
that under way by I believe the date is
December 29th of this year so that would
be a really good thing for them Gameloft
you will not ubisoft's but the GMO
brothers who run Ubisoft other company
was bought out by Vivendi last year
unfortunately it's not all good news as
windy as I said do still have 27% and
they've got twenty four point five
percent voting share as well which means
on the board when they're trying to pass
motions such as getting their employees
free shares in the company as part of
Barneses Vivendi in that case decided to
abstain from the vote meaning it didn't
go through sir they do still have an
impact on what happens with their with
the company you still playing destiny in
oh my god so much destiny had a great
run in crucible yesterday which has kind
of got me a little bit excited because I
am ban is coming back comes back next
week on the 10th on the race set and
there's gonna be new on
new shaders new stuff I don't know if it
continued shaders I just assumed it will
be and it's gonna be with with of course
the second iron Lord to hit the tower
lord saladin so to get to the iron
banner you have to complete a short quiz
you have to have completed the main game
complete a short quest and then you can
get into the iron banner which is PvP
4v4 and in the game mode will be control
so that's pretty exciting and that's not
the only thing that Bungie is bringing
to the game next week they're also
bringing the hard mode raid for the
Leviathan raid is gonna hit next week
and they've said that it doesn't change
so many things mechanically but it is
harder and it's not about getting your
character to progress it's about getting
unique rewards that will help you shine
I assume that means it's gonna be like
those cool auras that you see some
people sporting in the tower
SiC they're introducing a new thing
called season so right now we're in
season 1 which you might have seen when
you go and talk to walk thorn the lady
with the bird when she talks about clans
and you'll see that your season 1 clan
rep and all that stuff is there
season 2 is going to be outlined by
Bungie at twitchcon on October 20 at
4:30 p.m. during a livestream so who
knows what to expect yeah that all
sounds really cool I mean I think
they're definitely keeping to what they
said they won players to stay in their
game and not have to worry about not
having new content to get their hands on
once they hit end game and so far it
looks like that's working but let us
know what you guys think about it in
that comment box one of my favorite
party games to play is push-me pull-you
that's not how it works and house house
the developers have just announced the
hell latest game and it looks fantastic
it's basically Metal Gear Solid that's
how I would describe it okay I wouldn't
but it's basically about the new embody
a goose who's eject so any goose yes or
the worst
um but basically your goose was
impeccable handwriting which so far is
my favorite part of the game and the
short trailer gameplay trailer I suppose
you would say that they put on YouTube
is basically you trolling a poor
groundskeeper just trying to do his job
and you steal his keys and get him wet
and you take his hat and go on a little
picnic on your own you keep taking this
trowel and you just you be a real
nuisance so you be a guest so it looks
like it's a whole lot of fun
this one should release sometime in 2018
and at the moment it's titled untitled
goose game which is a parent
for the actual title of the game I'm
fully supportive of that being the
actual title 100% anything what about if
you called it gaggle gaggle there's a
gaggle of geese here we go here we go
dance review this game guaranteed to
make you gaggle can't say that on TV um
dude let us know in that comment box
what you think the game should be called
and what you thought of the trailer very
entertaining that's everything we have
for you this week I'm gonna go drive my
car but I don't have a car don't even
know how to drive one but I will be back
Monday Tuesday Wednesday Thursday Friday
next week to bring you all the news
you'll need and I will not be wearing
this one thing I'll see you then well
I'm off to drive my car by turning the
ignition they're the only two things I
know about cars that they call cars and
they have an ignition enjoy we're doing
weekend though today better well